the definition of passion is a strong
and barely controllable emotion listen a
strong and barely you can barely control
your emotion you know what I'm talking
about when I was a kid when I was a kid
13 years old you have to force me to get
off the baseball field me and my friends
would go to shore Canyon or we go to a
Wilson junior high school we'd play from
morning till night when it's dark we
couldn't catch the ball the back
baseball he would hit our eyes or our
face and then we stopped playing that's
how much we loved it was it was a strong
and barely controllable emotion I talked
to Tom earlier Tom and his wife Kim wake
up at 1:30 in the morning on Sundays to
watch Formula One races in Dubai and
they go for two and a half hours he's
obsessed about Formula one he introduced
me to Ayrton Senna and I got obsessed
about Ayrton Senna and my daughter's
name is center there's a passion there's
a certain strong feeling about it the
way you figure out your passion is by
answering three questions and I got this
from a book I read many years ago called
the leaderless revolution by British
diplomat he said three things you got to
figure out you're going to answer these
three questions one what do you love to
what do you hate three what bothers you
let me say it again take out a sheet of
paper write down what do you love what
do you hate what bothers you as you go
through this list circle the ones that
put the most fire in your belly
whichever one that just gets you jacked
up they can't stop thinking about what's
almost like you playing baseball you're
not doing it for money I figured out my
passion my passion has to do with
capitalism it has to do with freedom it
has to do with people it has to do with
helping people think for themselves that
you can make a decision for yourself
that drives me I can do this all day
long all night long
I don't want to go home because I love
what I'm doing it's part of my life you
got to figure out that passion for
yourself and it starts up with answering
those three questions what do you hate
what do you love what bothers you and
figure out a way to link this passion to
the business you're part of and if you
can do that and figure out a way to
monetize it you will never work a single
date for the rest your life